there are an increasingly vocal band of
brave Republicans willing to stick up
and be for it and again this is our
chance to pass this bill and I think
we'd all be making a mistake to be
diverted I don't intend to be thanks for
any reason believe Arafat is moving
against him off it was a very good
question was asked for a while
for a family of four six close to 60 for
family of three about 12 and a half
thousand i get too bad
I told her
15
is the president mentioned the Commerce
Department is releasing its annual
report has released it this morning on
income and poverty statistics for 1996
today's report suggests that American
living standards continued to rise and
that's good news at the same time
however the report suggests that there
is still challenges facing our economy
the typical American family's income
increased from nineteen ninety five to
nineteen ninety six poverty declined
slightly blacks experienced relatively
large increases in income and earnings
and the black poverty rate is at its
lowest level recorded these economic
gains in 1996 build on the progress
begun in 1993 in the two decades prior
to nineteen ninety-three median income
with stagnant and income inequality was
increasing from nineteen ninety three to
nineteen ninety six median income has
increased substantially and income
inequality has stabilized but clearly
there is still some challenges our
nation faces although the child poverty
rate fell this year it is still too high
and we still have too many children
without health insurance so it is clear
that we need to continue to focus on
improving the economic well-being of
children in the United States I'd like
to now quickly review some of the key
details in today's report first
beginning with some facts about income
gains median family income increased by
nearly five hundred dollars between 1995
and 1996 after adjusting for inflation
that builds on an even larger increase
of seven hundred and fifty dollars
between 1994 and 1995 in 1996
the median family had nearly 2,200
dollars more income in real terms than
in 1993 and the gains are particularly
striking for blacks who have experienced
increases in median household income of
nearly 2,300 dollars since 1993 per
capita income increased by four hundred
dollars between 1995 and 1996 again
after adjusting for inflation and per
capita income grew twice as rapidly for
blacks and Hispanics about 5% for both
groups income inequality has been
roughly flat since 1993 and that arrests
a trend for the previous 20 years in
which it had been rising blacks median
earnings as a fraction of whites median
earnings for male full-time year-round
workers rose from seventy-six percent in
nineteen ninety five to eighty percent
in 1996 that gap in earnings between
black and white workers wizard its
lowest level in the last 30 years the
with respect to the poverty rate overall
poverty rates declined slightly from
1995 to 1996 and the poverty rate in
1996 is now 1.4 percentage points lower
than it was in 1993 in 1996 the black
poverty rate hit a new low the black
poverty rate is declined by nearly five
percentage points since 1993 and it is
now at the lowest level since the census
developed its poverty measure using the
current population survey in 1996 the
child poverty rate fell but it still
remind remains high and it is notable
that fifteen percent of all children
still don't have health insurance so let
me conclude by
saying that our economy continues to
move ahead at a healthy pace jobs are
being created unemployment is low growth
is solid and inflation is in check and
today's numbers clearly illustrates the
benefits that accrue from that healthy
economy but there are challenges that
remain we need to reduce childhood
poverty and make sure the children are
insured we have made a start included in
this year's balanced budget deal of
course was 24 billion dollars to cover
up to five million additional uninsured
children so as we continue to build on
gains and family income certainly more
needs to be done to protect our most
vulnerable populations I'll stop there
to graduate let me just walk through a
couple of these and then what we'll be
happy to take questions obviously when
we came into office we had just had a
four year period where median family
income had fallen 1795 dollars so when
you look at the switch from a drop of
1795 going to a 2200 or 2169 dollar
increase over the last three years since
the economic plan passed you do have a
very significant change and then we've
also tried to focus on how what we've
done the balanced budget actually does
even more for people's take-home pay or
after-tax income for such a
middle-income family with two kids they
would have a thousand dollars in
addition to this based on the tax cut
even if they did a child tax credit even
if they did not use the education tax
cut and as the president mentioned
interest rates which averaged 8.2
percent 30-year rates in the previous
four years before we took office and now
have averaged in the sixes and are now
at a very low rate near six point four
percent is having very significant
mortgage savings for for many families
so the the overall story is certainly
one
a positive one we certainly have a long
way to go to to make up for two decades
of stagnation that preceded us but this
is significant significant progress just
want to stress a couple of other points
if there had been one statistic that had
probably been the most disturbing the
past had been that Hispanic family
income had not been up over the last
couple years this year Hispanic income
was up thirteen hundred and seventy-one
dollars five point eight percent which
is a very strong increase a really
dramatic one year increase and now
ensures that every group has seen the
real income go up since the passage of
the 93 plan the other thing that should
be gratifying to us is that if you look
at the different quintiles the bottom
twenty percent to the top twenty percent
since 1993 each of those quintiles each
group income group has seen their income
increase and i think that the chart that
we may have showed at the end bat shows
that shows that for the bottom twenty
percent the increase has been the grade
of six point eight percent so it is the
case that that all groups have been
joining in the prosperity on this year
the the statistics are for this one year
statistics are somewhat mixed while over
the last three years it is very positive
number this year if you look at pre-tax
income the bottom twenty percent was
down slightly if you look at after-tax
income which takes into account the
Earned Income Tax Credit increases the
President had you see that even the low
at bottom twenty percent had a three
point three percent after-tax income
free so in terms of their take-home
income all quintiles benefited and the
lowest twenty percent has had seen the
fastest rate of growth since 1993
as as Janet mentioned child poverty
which is certainly a major concern was
that twenty two point seven percent in
1993 it was a 20 point eight percent
last year now is at 20.5 percent again
all of these are very positive movements
in the right direction the levels our
still should be disturbing to all
Americans it should be disturbing and
hurtful to all Americans that one out of
five American children live in poverty
and it should be especially disturbing
to all of us that african-american child
poverty is almost double that rate again
though the important thing is that all
these are moving in the right direction
but it is also important to recognize
that there are still farther to go
significantly further to go when you
look at the poverty rate they do not
include the Earned Income Tax Credit
however the census shows an alternative
definition so that if you wanted to know
what was the degree that the you know
what impact with the Earned Income Tax
Credit have made or our increases in the
Earned Income Tax Credit have made if
that was counted in the poverty numbers
table c4 does show that those
alternative definitions and what it
shows was that in 1993 the Earned Income
Tax Credit at that time lifted 2.1
million families 2.1 million people out
of poverty in 1996 with the significant
increases in their own income tax credit
that numbers up to nearly 4.3 million so
you've had 2.2 million more taxpayers
not in poverty because of the Earned
Income Tax Credit increases and I think
that for us and for the president I
think it very much affirms the
importance of the battles that we have
had over the last several years not only
in increasing their own income tax
credit but also in repeated battles to
protect those increases in the battles
to protect Medicaid as a guarantee
as food stamps as a guarantee the
increase in the minimum wage and as the
president mentioned the important 24
billion dollars for children's health
care are all part of our effort going
forward to deal with the the high levels
that still exist even with the
significant improvements we've had one
final point I would make is on health
care you would note that that people
between the age of 25 and 44 actually
saw their in health insurance rates
improved slightly the reason why overall
number of health people of health
insurance rate got worse is because at
the youngest and oldest levels and with
nearly two-thirds of it being children
and so I think that this number confirms
very much the appropriate attention that
the president and the Congress addressed
the 24 billion dollar children's health
care initiative and with that Jan and I
would be happy to take any questions
economic inequality is continuing to
grow can you explain your methodology
what you're comparing to say that it's
leveled off well I'll let me let Jenna I
mean there's there's a gini coefficient
measure that's used I think that you see
that it it has little have gone up over
the last few years you know it's gone
you know down a little up a little bit
but kind of in the range that the census
would call flat because of their
statistical significance test so as you
know the president addressed that in the
portion of his speech where he was
saying there is more to do is certainly
an improvement have inequality flattened
as opposed to sharply increasing but
that's not good enough for us and it
shouldn't be good enough for four other
Americans our goal should be to see in
inequality measures improve but I think
that for most Americans they would
deeply care about the fact that
everybody is benefiting and the chart
that shows that at all quintiles the
median family at all quintiles our
median household at all quintiles
have seen growth since 1993 certainly
shows all groups are benefiting and
inequality has has flattened out and for
those who say that it's that we should
be more to improving it we say we agree
family incomes what does the president
think about the congressional testimony
about IRS excesses and abuses against
taxpayers and does he support this were
a bipartisan proposal that's floating
around Congress to take the what is it
the shift responsibility for watching
over the IRS from the Treasury to a new
board of directors um well first of all
the nobody who can watch the IRS
hearings cannot be extremely disturbed
by the accounts that were told the IRS
themselves have have said so clearly
every American looking at that would be
appalled by some of the abuse some of
the Bews a--'s and Treasury has been
active in trying to improve things and
streamline making it easier for people
to file the IRS as you know announced
very specific measures that they were
going to do so I don't think there's any
disagreement that the examples use drop
alling and that we need to take further
steps that that that there have been
reforms in the right direction that but
that much more needs to be done at the
IRS in terms of the management the
Treasury Department has a very sound new
management proposal that does rely on an
advisory board that includes top experts
but in terms of the proposal that would
turn over management of the IRS to a
part-time outside private board we think
that is extremely misguided it is I it
has been criticized by past our
Republican IRS commissioners by the
Brookings Institution it is a recipe for
conflicts of interest and the notion
that the right way to deal with these
problems with the IRS is to decrease
accountable
and have part-time managers who would be
themselves involved in a range of
financial transactions would be a
serious step backward so i think that
the Treasury Department has an important
reforms in place new board and we'll be
supporting that and we will vigorously
oppose the efforts to turn and turn over
the IRS management to part time outside
private people who again we think would
lead to a recipe for conflicts of
interest a less accountability and less
trust of the IRS or do you think that
they were isolated well I think in any
big organization there are going to be
disturbing cases that will happen I
think that but for any of us who are in
any kind of position of responsibility
that shouldn't be an excuse for trying
to take action to reduce those on the
other hand you know people should not
forget that the majority the
overwhelming majority of people work at
the IRS are you know honest hardworking
Americans who themselves pay taxes and
themselves found the examples they're
disturbing IRS agents have been the
targets of violent attack over recent
time so I think that from our point of
view the important thing is that there
are serious problems and we should
address them of course that should not
take away from the fact that there's
been many positive reforms and that
there are many that the overwhelming
majority of people who work there are
fine civil servants
the size of the organization but there
were photos for example that isn't just
some dunno guy out there I'm sorry I'm
sorry if in guys that would be
interpreted that way I said we believe
that there are our problems and that we
should be addressing addressing them and
if if there are prep I mean if there is
pressures to target poor people who
cannot defend themselves that is
appalling and that should be ridded out
of the system if there are you know
those type of enforcement quotas almost
in any organization we've seen in the
past tend to lead to pressure that leads
to abuse but I think that the people in
the IRS have to have recognized that and
said that they require require serious
efforts and are taking those efforts I
felt the question was that I feel that
represented everything there and I think
that it's responsible for all of us as
we're talking about this and reporting
on this to not to not create a situation
will restart creating a caricature of
many fine people who work in any
organization where there can be serious
problems again I said that's not an
excuse for not taking action and and and
we are have a very strong reform agenda
for that perform is enough to take care
of the public concerns about what they
heard last week people and equipment in
some of these reforms that that should
satisfy people's complaints of the IRS I
think people will look and see the look
for results I think the test will be you
know whether there is good reform and
positive results that that ridout these
abuses so I think I think people are
going to look and see whether they see
significant effort and significant
improvement
yes time oh good question you know you
know we can't say much on that now you
know I I'm not even a former fed member
so what I do anything about IRS and you
know why did all this stuff come out in
three days on the hill and it's
obviously been going on for so long well
I mean long before this the Treasury
Department has had an IRS management
reform proposal so this was not the
motivation for our reforms and secretary
Rubin and deputy director summers have
been working on this they have brought
in a new IRS commissioner who they think
is outstanding so we have been at work
as you know they have done significant
reforms that have made it easier for
people to file we have a new initiative
to reduce error rates and there are an
income tax credit that is in the budget
right now so to the extent of whether
there should have been additional
oversight hearings in the past I mean
that that's a question for the members
of Congress first of all with the
typical income and that incomes is
typical against a family
to family the typical I'm sorry the
typical family the typical that when we
said it rose to 490 it was rising for a
family for 40 2304 family what sciences
Oh what is the typical family yet it's
the median income of families or
families know when I say typical family
father mother how many children that's
what I'm talking about it's these
statistics are based on income overall
families and its median of all families
that includes all kinds of families so
you don't have a breakdown I mean there
are breakdowns of different kinds of
families the numbers of each type but
just statistically we say that's going
up median family income simply takes all
families and looks at the medium so it's
not for the typical second fire this
question but the games that you're
reporting what do you suppose
I check off but the proposal for the
sentences disenfranchised my northern
numbers and in essence make a another
whole race of minorities if that would
have happened and this was kind of
disenfranchised your numbers oh oh I
understand I i would i would let Sally
cats and answer that I'm sorry um can be
berry maybe you can do it argue that
these figures are is gained I'm just
gonna disappear in an extra session
we've got a bigger even I mean we well
we've we've made up ground we lost this
median family income fell nearly two
thousand dollars from 88 92 now in the
last three or four years we've gone
we've basically made up those games that
were lost the last time around I mean is
there any sense of permanence to this or
you mean to go to loose you have any
sense of what whatever session with you
these figures well well I mean I think
the important thing is that the the
fundamentals in the economy continue to
be exceptionally sound you know four
point nine percent unemployment
inflation slowed productive investment
has been in in in in double digits if
you look at the if you look at the blue
chip the 50 people in the blue chip not
a single one of them projects recession
next year not not a single one not a
single one even projects unemployment
over over six percent so I think that
you know we feel that that there have
been some important structural
improvements in the sense of the deficit
if you look at our deficit projection
now as opposed to 1993 you're talking
about having to projected less debt of
two trillion dollars over a period of
seven to ten years at that is a
significant impact on on the strength of
the economy and you can see it in the
fact that even though growth is bet
stronger now unemployment is lower
long-term interest rates are almost two
points lower than they were during the
previous administration even with a weak
economy
should be satisfied with the rates of
poverty of children and particularly
black children what do you what is the
administration working on to have less
than just a gradual effect on these
numbers are there any plans to to make
more dramatic improvement in those areas
that you say are still we should all
consider hurt well I think that we
certainly it had tremendous effect on
what we fought for at the end of the of
the budget if anybody here will remember
the last two items for us that held up
the balanced budget agreement was
getting full 24 billion for children and
as you recall making sure that the child
tax credit went to lower income workers
so when we were fighting for the
balanced budget we certainly had in mind
the fact that we were going to make sure
that every income group was was
benefiting benefiting plan or we
wouldn't have gone along with the
agreement right now we are going through
obviously our next budget process and we
will go through what our new initiatives
are and and I think that there will most
certainly be efforts in the area of
children to do more in this account but
a lot of it is making sure the things
we've set work I mean you have 24
billion for children's health care we
want to make sure that's implemented
work we have to fight unfortunately hard
every year just to protect the Earned
Income Tax Credit increases we have we
have a goal of getting to a million kids
and Head Start by the year two thousand
and two we've had over a forty percent
increase in head start funding since
we've been in office we spend over a
billion dollars more on weck so this is
something that we fight for every year
when we do our budget every single year
we have things in there for children
even in deficit reduction context that
we are fighting hard for and right now
we're fighting very hard for America
Reads and and for our testing initiative
which we also think are very important
to the overall benefit of children and
their education
the things which are not included in
these statistics are they going to make
dramatic improvements in the child
poverty rate well you said habitat
furnished aren't reflected in these
numbers are they going to have a
dramatic effect well I i mean the early
I mean first of all as you said it has
gone down from 22.7 to 20.5 so there has
been improvement that does not count the
Earned Income Tax Credit so that would
make it it would make it lower I mean
obviously some of the important things
is keeping the strength of the economy
getting the important vestments for
children making sure that welfare reform
is implemented in a way that that it
works and gets people into the workforce
and parents into the workforce so
they're supporting making more money
supporting their income and and all the
things that we are doing in terms of
fiscal responsibility open trade and
investment that we think are important
to a strong economy a strong economy a
tight labor force helps raise wages and
helps families move out of poverty and
certainly pulls on the marginal worker
you know when that when the unemployment
rate is tight it pulls on the marginal
worker into the workforce and helps
raise those incomes and just finally I'd
say we just had the second half of the
minimum wage increase take place on
September first which now if you look
from the two years before would help a
minimum wage worker by eighteen hundred
dollars from the 425 increase to the 515
increase Janet 11 no I certainly right
agree with everything that's on jeans
list I think those are the things that
we can have a positive influence on that
will work to reverse what has been a
very disturbing long-term trend but to
expect miracles overnight and that kind
of number I think we'd probably be
unrealistic but we're certainly doing a
lot and everything that we can to move
that number in the right direction yeah
obviously many of these issues will be
discussed in the White House Conference
on child care that will be coming up and
certainly will something will all be
listening to and may very well inform us
at the time of the budget decisions that
we will make a next year's budget paper
present growth of top ready is higher in
this economy low and post class that's
it difference income differences between
top and a lacrosse has been more big are
there any program in United States what
I'm shaking sorry Pope percent growth of
top money is higher than second and
middle and post cross that said
difference in income differences between
hope and a lacrosse has been more big
other than pass I think you seen this
well I if there is in the numbers that
gene passed out there is a slight
difference a slightly higher income
growth since 1993 for the top it doesn't
I don't think it's particularly law